Luke here at the AR Boys YouTube channel
and I'm here in the frozen tundra of
Alaska and for the next 3 days I'm
building Bushcraft shelters sleeping
under animal hides dealing with broken
equipment and I'm bringing you guys
along for the
[Music]
[Applause]
ride
welcome to the Tiga Forest of Alaska I
think it's time to do some
camping
so this is the tiger forest of Alaska
the word Tiga comes from Russian it
means little sticks in English we call
these Trees black Spruce and they grow
in the tundra and swamps of Alaska while
these swamps are very difficult to cross
in the summertime once they freeze over
we can explore them but first things
first I need to find a place to camp and
I actually like this spot quite a bit
most of these spruce trees you see are
dead an invasive Beetle called a spruce
bark Beetle came in here and wiped these
things out that means lots of building
material lots of
firewood the air temperature is about
13° fah and this ground is still not
frozen in the winter time the ground
temperature is usually a lot warmer than
the air temperature and the snow acts as
a blanket that traps that heat in the
ground if you can strip away the ice and
snow and build your shelter on thawed
ground it's going to be a whole lot
warmer and there's a bit of mud right
there this ground might be a little bit
more swampy than I first thought we'll
just have to deal with
it
all right I think it's time to start
cutting some
trees
I bought this Hatchet in Hiroshima Japan
last spring when I used it to take the
limbs off these
trees
is
it's uh 3:50 p.m. starting to get dark
it's this close to the Arctic we don't
get a lot of
sunlight well I better bust out my
lights
now
this wood is so wet everything's covered
in ice going to use one of these fire
starers
here there we
go yeah that's working you can tell
everything's wet when dead Pine doesn't
want to
burn
little fingers are getting a little
numb I get all the snow out of my
hair oh that feels
amazing
I've got a shelter I've got fire I think
it's time to start working on
dinner gloves are a bit wet I'm going to
go dry them by the
fire all right I got a sweet potato and
a little bit of tin foil here we're
going to wrap that up there you go got a
nice pile of coals
here to bury that sweet potato in the
coals for about 45
minutes most Foods cook at around 375 de
F hold your hand over the fire and count
one 2 3 and when you can get to three
without it hurting that's about 375° F
so right about
here as the fire kind of changes you
need to adjust your
meat I like a little bread with my steak
so I brought along some bread dough I
made this up like a week ago and didn't
use it so I threw it in the fridge and
it's still good yeah just got a little
bit more of that sourdough
goodness oh pretty little piece of bread
right there we're going to have some
herbal
tea
let oh that's done put that
there let's take a
peek well that's looking pretty
good some honey and butter I'm going to
put on there sweet potato is so mushy
it's exactly how it should be going to
put a little cinnamon on my sweet potato
and on my
bread we got sweet potato and cinnamon
honey butter and bread and two massive
chunks of seasoned
steak there you go this is my cow horn
mug I made this also made this griddle I
got a video explaining how I made these
things it's pretty easy I'll put a link
in the video description
below M there
good oh that was good still got quite a
bit of this steak left just go sit it in
the snow bank and it'll be good
tomorrow there we
go oh that warms me up peach heral tea
with loads of sugar in it tastes pretty
good and it's just more fun drinking it
out of a cow
horn that is good
right I really love this fork and plate
both of them are antiques the fork is
about 150 years old it's from the Civil
War era handles made out of cow bone
this is my fancy camping
wear well now that we've had a fire in
here for several hours we're starting to
figure out what the ground situation is
over here it is really soft like look at
this that is just a big swampy spot
right there so I think we're going to
end up sleeping on this side well it's
pretty clear that I need to make a bed
if I sleep straight on the ground I'm
going to get soaking wet and
frozen I'm re feeling my water jug just
a cup or two at a time got to melt a lot
of snow to get 2 L of water
[Music]
these logs are all wet and covered in
ice so I'm going to try to dry them out
and warm them up before I sleep on
them
so I got all my firewood for the night
and I got it propped up around the fire
trying to dry it
out I didn't bring any sleeping bags or
sleeping pads but I brought my Caribou
hide Caribou have these thick Hollow
hairs they're really warm they double a
caribou hide over on it self it's pretty
thick actually gives you some cushion
and lots of
insulation let's see how lumpy this is
going to
[Music]
be wow I'm tired it's almost 10:00 I'm
pretty
tired well instead of a sleeping bag I'm
going to be sleeping underneath a bison
hide tonight I use the Bison because
it's one of the few animals big enough
to cover me I'm kind of a big boy the
nice thing about using animal hides when
you're sleeping next to a fire is that
these won't burn up Sparks can land on
them the fire can get real hot doesn't
matter you'll wake up long before these
things catch on fire it's going to be
very cold tonight and my water bottles
will freeze solid if I don't keep them
near the fire so I'm going to put them
just right down
here
all right to put some hot coals
underneath my bed get it nice and
toasty
it is late and I am tired I will see you
guys in the
morning oh good morning stayed pretty
warm but the bed is so
hard oh my feet are cold though my feet
stick out from underneath the hide a
little
bit oh that feels good get my toes
warmed
up uh Frozen
boots how many times have I put on
Frozen boots and to warm up the honey
butter
oh that's
beautiful got melted honey and butter
I'm going to shake that
up fresh warm bread and honey
butter
all right time to get up and do some
stuff it is definitely colder today if
I'm going to stay warm I'm going to need
to make this shelter a whole lot
better let me show you something weird
about snow you can see this right here
is the path I made with my snow shoes
yesterday you can see where yesterday I
walked on it without snowshoes and I
sunk in but today it's rock hard if you
stomp a trail down with snowshoes and
let it sit overnight it'll freeze up and
turn really hard snowshoes are great for
building paths in the snow like
this
I want to push this snow burn back a
little bit and make a little bit more
room so I've been throwing my tree limbs
and logs in here takes a long time for
the fire to melt the snow but it's a lot
better than
shoveling woo
there we
go
oh well now that I got lunch in me I
think it's time to start building
again
[Music]
there we go got my stove installed
hopefully this will keep me nice and
warm well I got my shelter set up just
in the nick of time it's already
starting to get dark luckily I already
have a lot of firewood laying around I'm
not going to need as much as I did last
night
[Music]
I am almost completely out of water so
we're going to go melt some snow been
getting a lot of pine needles and pine
cones in my drinking water so I'm going
to go find a spot a little further away
from the
trees
there we
go got my
leftovers woo it is
frozen I'll just put it over here
hopefully it'll thaw out well now that
I've got a wood floor instead of all
that mud I can change into my little
slippers
nice I can put my my boots up here on
the wall to keep them from freezing in
the
night oh it's nice to get my slippers
on all my wood is cold and wet so I'm
putting it on top of the stove to dry
out and warm up then it'll burn really
well when it comes time to feed the
fire
well it's about 5:00 and uh I'm in for
the night so I think I'm going to start
making to some dinner all right I got
some black beans
here these onions are
frozen
so that when the drummed column arrived
the British would be rotten and give way
well we got a little smoke going
[Music]
on the logs over on that side we're
starting to smolder you tell the logs
are getting hot there pine sap bubbling
out of
them have to watch it carefully you
don't want anything starting on
fire oh yeah that's thought out nicely
it's warming up
well all right just added some rice
SM this smells so
good all
right put a little hot sauce on
there I'm so hungry this smells
amazing I tell you what beans and rice
are an amazing camping food not only are
they delici ious it's non perishable and
takes up hardly any room in your
backpack oh that's so
good want to check something here 2° fah
compare that to what's inside the
shelter put it right there give it a few
minutes to warm up all right it's been a
few minutes and you can see it's just a
little over 50° fah here at the bed I
mean it's not exactly warm but that's a
lot better than outside but watch this
I'm going to put the thermometer on the
ground there on the floor it's about 22°
when you're sleeping in a heated shelter
the higher you can make your bed the
better you want your bed to be at least
as tall as your heat Source ideally a
little bit
taller
well I've been in the shelter 5 hours
and I've already gone through 2/3 of my
firewood so had to go out and cut some
more oh got to split that
too I think it's time to go to
bed I'll see you guys in the
morning
tell you what I slept a lot better last
night was a lot warmer and more
comfortable but I did have to wake up a
bunch to stoke the fire I woke up uh
about 2:00 a.m. the first time and then
at 3: 4:30 and then 6 and then 6:30ish
or so I was pretty much up
so for breakfast I've got an omelette I
made this at home it's got sausage and
vegetables cheese eggs went and thre it
in a vacuum sealed bag and then froze it
now all I got to do is just warm it
up all right got my honey butter sitting
over here
melting
[Music]
it's getting hot in here yesterday it
was cold even with my jacket on and the
stove going full blast I've got the
stove turned down to halfway and it's
still hot in here and it has to do with
all this Mass inside the tent there's
400 lb of wood in here there's all my
gear there's the ground the tent itself
all that stuff needs be heated up and it
takes a long time but once it all gets
warm it stays really hot in here it gets
really nice and even when the stove goes
down it stays warmer in here for a
longer
time doesn't that look good this is so
much better than dehydrated
eggs all right well I think it's
starting to get up and face the day oh I
got to tell tell you it is so nice to
have a floor in this tent it's it's so
much warmer and it's so nice not to have
my feet down in the mud it's an absolute
luxury oh look at this my pants are all
dry my mittens are all
dry I always bring backup food for a lot
of reasons and I had this bit of pork
here that I didn't get to use and I was
keeping it underneath my bed to keep it
cold a mouse got into it ate up all that
pork see that it's probably a v or
leming I'll just cut off that part it's
still good I have more trouble with mice
than any other animal hands down and the
longer you camp in one spot the worse
the problem becomes it's like more and
more mice find you when the mice get
really bad they'll start coming in at
night and grabbing your hair and pulling
out bits of your hair to make their nest
it's it's not great all
righty oh it's 10:00 a.m. and we're just
in time for the
sunrise uhoh that's not
good uh car doesn't want to start and it
sounds like it's the battery it's 0
degrees Fahrenheit right now so I
wouldn't be surprised if the battery's
so cold that it just doesn't want to
start
[Applause]
make sure it doesn't doesn't overheat I
just need to raise the temperature of
the battery like 20 30° I don't need to
boil
[Music]
it all right that's feeling
warm all
right
I'm going to try to warm up the engine
block and see if that helps fortunately
the engine block is way back
there I got to be careful this K truck
is sitting on top of 18 in of snow the
snow gives way and it settles it's going
to squish me all right we're going to
give that 30 minutes or so and see see
if that doesn't
help well there she is once I got it all
dialed in it was really nice this would
have made a really good long-term
shelter it's warm but it's not hot
obviously this is a little bit sketchy
got to make sure you don't catch
anything on fire or melt any wires or
anything
oh it's like a chich and Chong video in
here a smoke coming
out
aha
woohoo this is living in Alaska in a
nutshell stuff goes wrong things break
and you just got to deal with
it you know it's not like I could call a
tow
truck engine's warmed up let's see if we
can get out of
here
well that was a good time hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video and if you want
to see more videos from the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel make sure to click
subscribe activate that notification
button and I will see you guys guys in 2
weeks if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning and hit that Bell button so
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching